[Music]
all right so going into how to secure
the mount so this is the first point
okay and the first point is Discovery
learning so you're going to learn the
difference between tension and
relaxation and what it does to your
perceived weight okay so he's going to
bench press me up and n10 and he can do
it pretty easily again just being what
you think is normal okay and then he'll
bench up and do it no problem okay it
doesn't matter if you're low I'm low
bench is up can do it no problem okay so
what you're going to do now in your
Discovery learning is just relax he goes
to bench
and you're a lot
heavier understand the Instinct that
when you feel yourself to lift you might
tense up that's going to make you
liftable so when you feel that he's
lifting you that's the time to release
more and you get heavier so what what
did you
feel say it loud enough so the camera
can hear a lot of dead weight okay like
the weight was straight in your arms not
just for you sir yeah okay and and then
so
what happens is if the guy starts
lifting he starts wasting energy and you
make him enter into the fatigue cycle
okay and that's what we want to happen
Okay lesson to reinforcing the m is the
use of anchor points or leverage points
okay and uh you have under the head here
and the goal is not not to pick him up
the goal is for example if he's pushing
me up that he picks his head up with me
okay so you don't want to burn your
bicep out another Anchor Point is either
the hook on one leg or the or the hook
or both legs
okay and then always reinforce this with
understanding your base of support okay
so you want it to be as wide as possible
and you want your post to be uh
reinforcing against the direction that
he might be trying to generate an angle
of disturbance so for example if if he's
trying to throw me this way to my this
way then he goes and the hook to the
head is going that way if I if he goes
that way again and he goes the other way
again then then you hook the head and
you can see that your post is out here
okay likewise you can see that I am
reinforcing this Great Vine over here
I'm kind of loose on this one you can
even take it out to keep that knee to
reinforce that post on both sides okay
so I'm going to relax he's going to try
to push in different angles and I'm just
hooking basing brake
lining do for a while get
tired combining all of these things
to not waste
energy okay and make him again enter
deeper into the fatigue cycle right is
tiring yes sir is it tiring yes sir okay
all right the next series is a matter of
I'll deframe him so they'll tend to push
on various places okay some are smart
and just some are stupid um and it's a
result that he can't he feels like he
can't get you off and he's getting more
and more more tired that's where they
make more mistakes okay so um I not not
not necessarily a dumb one but he's
trying to push my knee down and look for
elbow knee Escape he's trying to get out
okay so you're doing all your other
stuff you're relaxing he goes to do that
and you just pop it okay so all I'm
doing is cupping it and moving it out of
the way
okay um another one is is heel chest
push again you can make him enter deeper
into that cycle by make by for example
if we're here and I relax and especially
if I have a h head hook he'll never work
he'll never get it and he'll
stop well you can make him more fatigued
by making him think he's getting it by
fluctuating how much tension you have
and then you made him work and you'll
can swim in okay so he's here let just
show what I'm doing I'm just kind of
swimming in the shoulder and coming back
down to base
okay
um another one is I can use my body to
do all this kind of stuff so for example
he's pushing up I kind of get him going
and I just
turn he's there and I'm turning like
that and then I just kind of smash the
lack of Leverage that he had on the
chest push okay um so you you kind of
mix these things up he's going to go for
a while
and then you got him deeper into the
fatigue sidey right yes sir okay let's
try it okay this next one to help
reinforce m is arm isolations okay and
in essence you're trying to get his
elbows away from his torso is what
you're trying to do so uh we're going to
work on two
okay um you can see I did it came out
last time so as as he goes to he's
pushing right and I came this way okay
and you can crawl
up this way okay and now you can hold it
any number of ways uh just to keep his
arm his elbow away from his body the
technique I want you to work on is uh
resist don't let don't let me get that
there you go and you're just going to
crawl it out like this you can wait and
keep them in the f
cycle and then you can get it as he
starts to fatigue okay so we'll work on
that arm isolation
first okay the next arm isolation is any
anytime he like reaches up or crosses
over his own Center Line if he reaches
up I can make him cross over his own
center line but sometimes they they will
do that okay
uh so for example if he's trying to push
to the side right and he just crossed
over his own Center Line and you'll have
this arm isolation here you know my body
weight is on there
okay
um or he pushes straight up right and
then I push it over and then you have
this arm isolation here right here okay
and you you do you combine that with all
your Mount securing aspects we've done
so far Okay so again either pushed up I
yielded and pushed it over and then
bring my weight down on the elbow do you
feel that okay or he pushed to the side
himself right what it doesn't matter and
you you can do the same thing either
with your hand or you can use your body
to do it and you have it again and it's
trapped underneath there again okay so
we'll work that arm isolation so you can
combine These Arm isolations so let's
say he pushed is I pressed it over and
he's going to start getting very
desperate on the other hand cuz you he
can't push at all on that hand so as he
starts to push this is where you can
start to work and you can get both arms
isolated in here like that okay so one
more time on that move go slow okay so
he goes to push I pass come down on it
he'll start to feel the helplessness
there there this arm will start to push
and that's easy for you now to isolate
it and you come in here in this Gable
grip and then you can secure your Mount
any way you want but you have both arms
isolated now so combination of the two
arm
isolations all right so another arm
isolation double double arm isolation so
somehow he he goes so he can either go
here and I can do this cross one here
and then of course you have the gift
here
okay or he's he's pushing on the leg
right and then you do this one and
you'll pass it around and then you have
the GP wrap again over here okay so once
you get the GP wrap I'm going to cap the
elbow push and pull and turn them
towards the other arm okay and when I do
that I got to make space I got to come
up so when I'm here like this I'm going
to turn him boom and I'm on his he's on
his side like that and your weight is
still on him everything is still tight
and the arm has been less mobile as
you're doing that if you feel you need
more you can continue to turn him all
the way around making sure his elbow is
on the other side of
6:00 okay and once you're there you can
let go of the gift wrap and now you have
your double pin do you feel that yes sir
okay and so the arm is trapped here so
one more
time somehow you got the arm
Cross or you came up and you got it
across find the gift wrap cap turn
him get the elbow on the other side at 6
o00 and then go back to this Mount and
now you have the double arm pin okay
if you if you feel the need to uh
whatever that might be for your incident
environment to disengage and tactically
reposition or go to another Force option
okay so disengage and go to another
Force option all right so you were doing
your your Mount securing business he's
pushing you got a cross body right here
okay so once you have one we'll work on
the the lowest level of control so I
have one here I use my weight onto that
to come over to side control and from
side control I'll push up on that tricep
and I'll come up and I'll go away from
him towards his head where you would
draw your for op do it one more
time he's going right boom here here off
keep it on Boom over Force option okay
all right let's do the second Tac rep
position again somehow he goes whatever
okay I got that one and then I get this
one and I'm in here like that okay and
you're going to do the same thing so
undo here same up boom and around
one more
time he goes to
Bush here my weight is on that tricep
you feel it sure okay and then control
push up towards the head for sock okay
the last tactical
position is he keep's going okay you got
it and you went for the gift WRA and
then you went for the back okay and now
you're on your back again you come out
the tricep way so here like that there
still weight on you right okay and then
you put up and you're out you come
towards the feet on this one
okay one more time
[Music]
he's
going get you go to the back Mount you
want
off okay let's try